foreign
how many of you take insulin or know
someone who does
wow a lot of you and how many of you eat
hard cheeses like parmesan Swiss or
cheddar
yes now would you care if I told you
both insulin and heart cheeses are made
from genetically modified organisms
I cared insulin is great because it
saves lives
cheese is great because it makes life
worth living
but when you add GMOs to the equation I
feel uneasy scared
to staple even
yeah I wouldn't have been able to tell
you why
I couldn't have given you the rational
basis for my feelings
this is an example of using mental
shortcuts to decide what is good and
what is bad
we all take shortcuts every day often
without realizing they're necessary to
avoid cognitive overload and often
helpful as they build on stories we've
heard before
but they're not foolproof
the consequence of using mental
shortcuts is that we don't stop to weigh
the pros and cons
and we don't stop to check if our
conclusions are consistent with our
beliefs
and that can get us into trouble
especially with high stakes decisions
like what food we eat
food is core to our survival it's
sustenance
by 2050 the global population is
expected to rise by 50 percent while
arable land is expected to degrade even
faster
and our food system already accounts
over a third of global greenhouse gas
emissions
how can we possibly feed the world in a
sustainable way
technological innovations like lab grow
meat or rnai pesticides are a few
budding answers to that question
but they're novel and uncertain to many
of us in our shortcuts tend to push us
to reframe Innovation as scary or risky
let's talk about reframing food
innovation
because for these Technologies to be
successfully developed and adopted the
science needs to work of course
but you and I also need to see them as
part of our future
because we have a say through our
wallets Social Circles and elected
officials
over the last eight years I've studied
how our shortcuts can lead to rational
decisions as well as how to override
them
with this expertise in Behavioral
Science I help design marketing
strategies for Fortune 500 companies
with the goal of changing consumer
Behavior
most notably I helped a covid vaccine
manufacturer understand the shortcuts
leading to vaccine hesitancy and design
a communication strategy to cut through
them
the key to changing Behavior I learned
is to change the framing
I'll share my own story of recognizing
then overriding shortcuts in order to
reframe genetic modification
one example of food Innovation and share
why reframing is important for all of us
genetically modified organisms have had
their genes altered in a lab sometimes
by introducing genes from other plants
or animals
when I heard that my mind went to
Franken food a tomato with fish gills a
corn cob with caterpillar legs
I didn't want to know more
I was averse to ambiguity in this case a
less familiar form of food production
regardless of whether or not it could be
good for me
I also remember hearing about Monsanto
one company behind GMO development
the media mentioned it sued Farmers for
replanting rather than rebuying their
genetically modified seeds
when I heard that my mind went to David
and Goliath Monsanto was Goliath
Monsanto was the face of GMOs therefore
GMOs were bad
I didn't want to know more
instead I reactively devalued any
information from GMO companies after
that
including the research on GMO safety
because I didn't like the source
ambiguity aversion
and reactive devaluation
are two of the many shortcuts I took in
evaluating GMOs
wasn't until last year when I was
researching my own answers to that
question of how can we possibly feed the
world in a sustainable way
that I was forced to revisit GMOs
as part of this research I spoke to
nearly 50 food experts from plant
geneticists to organic farmers and
learned that GMOs can actually help us
tackle big Global issues like climate
change nutrition food security
farmers in India and Bangladesh may not
lose their entire rice crop to flooding
their genetic modification to withstand
submergence
and a farmer in Tanzania can feed his
family and send his kids to school with
the triple yield of his maize crop
through genetic modification to tolerate
drought
and nearly half a million children
around the world may not go blind every
year due to vitamin A deficiency if
golden rice a genetically modified
variety that can help combat this
deficiency were widely available
it was developed in the 1990s and yet
grown for consumption for the first time
only in 2022 nearly 30 years later
now not all GMOs have been rejected by
us though nearly 200 million people
around the world take insulin which is
made from genetically modified bacteria
and nearly 90 percent of the hard
cheeses eaten in the U.S are made with
genetically modified enzymes called
rennet previously we could only get from
killing young cows and that also made
cheese more expensive
the framing of saving lives for insulin
and making cheese more affordable and
Humane for rennet nudge me to see the
benefits of this technology
whereas Franken food and Goliath
pushed me to only see its risks
the difference in framing let me review
the same technology as good in one case
and bad in another
when I change the framing of genetic
modification to saving lives
I started to see the benefits
it made me wonder what other Innovations
could I be holding back due to my own
shortcuts
and if all of us are doing this
then what is the opportunity cost on a
global level
we need to reframe food innovation
here's what helped me
first I push myself to articulate the
rational basis for why I didn't like a
particular technology
when I couldn't I knew there were holes
in my frame
second I try perspective taking of those
with a different View
in my case experts who advocate for this
technology to combat my confirmation
bias
and third I change my reference point
from what we have to lose
to what we stand to gain
to not be too anchored on the wrists
consider trying this approach too
next time you're facing an unfamiliar
food technology
ask yourself
am I being rational
why might someone have a different view
than mine
and what can be the upside of innovation
then we can make choices rooted in
rational hope
rather than irrational fear
and we have so much to hope for
because we have budding solutions to not
just feed but nourish future Generations
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]